what if I were to tell you that you can
make a latte at home not only that you
don't even need one of those fancy
espresso machines all you need is some
good old science oh and some xanthan gum
which I guess counts the science anyway
oh and this latte is also dairy-free
for those of you with disagreeable
stomachs here's what you do bring
yourself some coffee and put it in a
blender depending on the volume of
coffee you're working with add point one
percent xantham gum that's about one
gram per liter then just slowly ramp up
your blending you'll end up with a drink
with all the consistency of a latte but
none of the dairy but what your coffee
does now have mixed in is the excretions
of many many bacteria manufacturers make
xantham gum by feeding bacteria lots of
sugar the sugar that the bacteria can't
eat it uses out as a coating this is the
magic stuff that makes up xantham gum
it's great at boosting viscosity thus
you get the texture of a latte without
the milk and without ever having to call
a medium coffee a grande I mean let's be
real